>>Female Presenter: And I'm really excited
to introduce our speaker for all you here
today. His name is Bill Wallauer. And he's
from the Jane Goodall Institute. So, let me
tell you a few fun facts about Bill. All right,
fact number one: For 15 years, Bill spent
almost every day following chimpanzees in
Tanzania and Africa.
And during that time, he spent more time with
chimpanzees than he did with humans. Fact
number two: Bill has served as a cameraman
and scientific adviser for more than 30 shows
on the BBC, Animal Planet, and The Discovery
Channel, including the very popular "Planet
Earth" series. Fact number three: In the early
1990s, he successfully captured a video of
wild chimpanzees giving birth on tape and
got asked by Jane Goodall to join the Jane
Goodall Institute.
>>Bill Wallauer: So, thanks so much for coming
out. My name is Bill Wallauer. And I think
you can see from that video, I kinda like
my job. So maybe next to a Google employee,
I'm probably the most happily employed employee
on the planet.
[laughter]
Yeah, I keep reading how this is the best
place in the world to work. And I keep thinking,
"They've never been in my forest."
[laughter]
Anyway, this next slide. Have any of you ever
seen a Jane Goodall talk? A couple of you.
And Jane, I got a message from Jane to send
a greeting. And we've already heard that greeting.
But let's hear it again. This is Jane with
her classic chimp greeting to all of you.
[Jane Goodall makes chimpanzee sounds]
And that's that wonderful chimp call, which
we've been hearing in the forest now. Me,
for 20 years. Jane, for about 60 years, as
we go through the forest. And that's just
a chimp greeting to all of you from Jane.
Thanks so much for coming out. So, a lot of
people ask me now how do they get involved
in this work? And I have really three people
to credit, my mom on the left side. This is
my mom as she was growing up. She was from
the East Coast, a traveler, English teacher,
very cultured, from Charlottesville. My father
on the top right, he was a professional rodeo
cowboy.
Grew up in the mountains in California. And
so, I got this great mix of both worlds. So,
we'd be at a Shakespearean festival in Ashland
one weekend and then Dad and I would go up
to Northeastern Oregon and go fishing the
next weekend. And so, I'm from Oregon originally.
And so, I owe--. Is somebody from Oregon here?
Yay.
[laughter]
A great state. And so, I owe them just so
much for giving me that sense of wonder about
both human culture and also about wildlife.
And it's just been a wonderful ride. And then,
of course, Jane Goodall, who always a hero.
I met her as a Peace Corp volunteer in 1989,
and instantly fell in love with her and her
mission. Yeah, to find out more about that
mission, I really encourage you to find out
more about her. She is certainly a pioneer
in more than just chimp research in conservation,
in the way she views the world. She is a true
living philosopher and visionary.
So, from my background, climbing around these
hills and mountains in Oregon gave me a very,
very good background to do the same kind of
work that Jane did in the early 1960s. And
so, it's not such a different forest. Very
different climate, but not such a different
forest. So I just, with my two years in the
forest as a Peace Corp volunteer and my knowledge
of Swahili, I was the perfect fit for Jane.
And this is what I looked like in, when I
first went out. I was in my mid-20s. This
is about '92. And very, very green around,
green in the field; didn't know very much
about chimps or very much about film-making.
And within a year of the Jane Goodall workout,
I had totally gone bush.
[laughter]
You've all heard the Jane Fonda workout? Well,
that's got nothing on the Jane Goodall workout.
[laughter]
So, I totally got into it, went completely
bush. And just Jane, I filmed this birth that
Winnie talked about. And Jane said, "Well,
why don't you just do this full-time? Let's
get a research, visual imagery to go along
with the long-term data," which they had been
collecting at that point for 30 years.
So, now we have a thousand hours of research
footage of every aspect of chimp behavior.
But then, film groups would come, film crews
would come and they would realize, "Well,
wow. This is really steep and really thick
and our scientific adviser can actually get
through this stuff just like a chimp can."
And so, I would be keeping up with the chimps,
trying to radio them, "Catch up, catch up.
All this stuff's going down." And they would
be a hundred yards behind me trying to keep
up. And so, pretty soon they started giving
me the camera and teaching me how to shoot
for film-making, which is a very different
art than doing chimp research home movies,
which I was learning how to do.
So, I got this great crash course in chimp
behavior from the chimps and in film-making
from these visiting film crews. So, as Winnie
said, I worked on about 30, 35 films. And
this pinnacle now is this; I think many of
you have heard about the "Chimpanzee" film
by Disney Nature. I was one of the cinematographers
for that, which is, as a wildlife cameraman,
just a dream job on so many levels.
But particularly for me, because it gives
me a platform to actually come to people like
you and talk about not only how amazing chimps
are, but the fact that within my lifetime,
at the rate we're going right now with the
Equatorial forest, the African forests, they
could be gone in my lifetime. So, that also
gives us a really amazing platform to talk
about chimps and chimp conservation.
So, Gaia still very much has my heart. And
it was absolutely amazing when on my visits,
I would be there for ten, eleven months out
of the year, and you could imagine, like during
the 90s, there was a lot going on technologically.
You might be aware of that. I missed all that.
[laughter]
And I just heard rumors about this Google
thing. I'm a real map person. I love my maps.
I love being able to see where I'm going and
see where I've been. And you could imagine
my delight when I could get on Google Maps
and mark the tree that Gaia was born in. I
mean, is that cool or what?
[laughter]
So, you could go on Google Earth and check
out the tree that Gaia was born in. That is
absolutely intriguing. You hear about Jane's
Peak. It was just off Jane's Peak in the tree
that Gaia was born. But it's this tree.
[laughter]
For those of you who are scientist-minded,
this is Parinari curatellifolia was the species
of the tree that she gave birth in.
[laughter]
And this is Gaia now. This is now 19 years
later. She has a baby of her own. And guess
what we called the baby? We called it--. We
have G-family, so Gremlin had Galahad and
Gaia, and Goldy and Glitter.
Do you see the pattern there? Fifi has Freud,
Ferdinand, and Faustino. So, we named them
through the female line by their--. And so
we thought, "Well, what would be an obvious
name to name another G-baby?" So, there we
go.
[laughter]
[clapping]
Born about June 4th, within a day or two of
June 4th, 2009. So, Google, meet Google.
[laughter]
And like the chimps, the chimps are obviously
aware that I am there, but don't think about
me at all. But hopefully, you'll be involved
and follow Google's life. And she will never
be aware of you. So, it's a very one-sided
relationship. But that's the way it has to
be because that's one thing this movie has
been able, something it's been able to do
for me is like, be a voice for chimps.
And so--. We talked a little bit about my
background. Did you see the "Planet Earth"
series? I mean, I haven't seen most of these
series 'cause I spend all of my time in East
Africa filming, but "Planet Earth" was one
that I filmed, "Life of Mammals," both of
which were produced and directed by Alastair
Fothergill, who came to me with this Disney
idea.
And that was one of the shortest decisions
of my life, next to saying "yes" to Jane,
"Will I come to Gombe?" From 2008 to last
summer, I got to spend on and off three years
filming for this Chimpanzee project for Disney
Nature, which was just wonderful. But what
does it take to make it happen? They didn't
tell me about this part.
[laughter]
I kind of pictured, 'cause often I'd get a
shot list, which is the list of shots that
a film crew wants. They don't even send a
producer. They'll just send a camera and a
shot list and a tripod and I'll start my work.
We did that for "Planet Earth" and for "Mammals."
And I did a couple BBC series. But in this
case, I stopped by Bristol, England to pick
up equipment and I thought it was gonna be
a few boxes and bags.
We had 22 hard cases plus our luggage plus
all our carry-ons. We were, my wife and I,
my wife has done this with me for about ten
years now. She did the sound. So, when you
go see the film, she did--. Just close your
eyes once in a while and just listen to the
wonderful sounds of the forest. That's all
Kristin's sound.
And she did the production stills as well
for this film. But yeah, the initial shock
at having to carry and be responsible for
about 500,000 dollars' worth of boxes and
bags and camera equipment was extraordinary.
And then the other thing, we get to our field
site and then we have to buy two months' worth
of food to add another ten, twelve boxes to
our boxes.
And then, we'd also go to these wonderful
open food markets where--. I mean, I just
experienced your open food market, which was
quite nice I'll have to say.
[laughter]
But there's nothing like an African open market
with all the tropical fruit: the mangoes,
the pineapples and just all the food that
we can get. And we loaded up and happiness
is seeing this city in my rear view mirror.
You can imagine. Hit the open road and it's
just extraordinary. That shot on the left,
a beautiful lake in the middle of Africa,
but not every scene we see is amazing. I mean,
this is chimp's habitat and the distance in
this upper right shot, but that's a tea plantation
surrounding it. You get the same in all over
West Africa: coffee, chocolate.
There's a lot of unsustainable removal of
these forests for the things that we in the
West and East have a hugely high demand for.
So, part of our messaging is as far as a conservation
organization is make sure you know where you're
buying and eating that stuff. Make sure you
know where it comes from because if we don't,
the result of that, like the African hardwood
demand, which is pretty much developed country-wide,
you can buy all kinds of African hardwood
in this country.
Just be sure you know where your wood's coming
from when you need to build something. Obviously,
we need to keep utilizing. We need to keep
building. It's just a matter of sustainability.
I have a feeling I'm preaching to the choir
here, but it's still worth saying. And so,
this is, as soon as we turn off the main road,
this is what the road looks like. It is extraordinary
getting to the field site, about a nine and
a half hour drive.
And then, we enter this forest, this magical
kingdom of the chimps, which you'll see in
the film. I hope you all plan on going. It's
just an amazing, amazing place, this magical,
150-, 200-foot canopy. Layers of canopy unlike
anything we see here anymore. It's still untouched,
phenomenally beautiful and absolutely worth
saving.
And this is home sweet home. We lived in this
tent, on and off. We have a little hut in
Gombe National Park, where Kristin and I have
lived for 12 years together. But in this field
site, we just lived in this tent. And on the
right is our technology base tent. So, I would
have my computer, hard drive, HD screen.
Kristin would have her stack of hard drives
for all her sound and stills. We ran that
off both solar and a little generator. And
so, we would come back from ten, eleven hours
in the field and then have to download 50
Gigs of data from our computers. And we could
not have done this without the amazing crew,
the field assistance there.
So, I wanted to show you, this is our group,
but Kristin's not in it because she's always
taking the pictures. So, I finally got her
in front of the camera for this one. This
is just on a break during a shooting day in
the forest. And this is our commute to work.
[laughter]
There's no traffic except for the occasional--.
Occasionally, we would run into an elephant
herd and that's like, serious traffic because
you are stopped in your tracks for a long
time because they will spread out. And if
they run into you in this forest, it's like
you can't see the traffic. It's stopping you
because if you run head to head in a mom who
has a kid, it can be really, really dangerous.
But you would know they were there. You could
hear them rumbling. They do this deep [elephant
rumble noise]. You hear this sound in the
forest like, "Oh, shh."
[laughter]
"What's gonna happen?" And so, you back off
and look where you need to go and try to get
around them. But I just thought this shot
was fun. Can we get those lights? I didn't
know those were so bright. Can we kill those?
>>Male #1: Then we can't see you.
>>Bill Wallauer: That's OK. Oh, it's not OK
for you as a videographer. I have no sympathy
for you. I was filming in a black forest.
[laughter]
Dark chimps in a black forest. Come on. Man
up here.
[laughter]
Anyway, if there wasn't this light on me,
you could see the--. Well, you can see on
the left side. This is an elephant footprint.
[tearing sound] All the way around here. I
just love this because there's a chimp footprint
in it.
There's a baboon. Bush pig. And up at the
top, just out of the frame, is a buffalo print.
They also clog the road a little bit if there's
a herd of buffalo. You stop and reroute. Your
GPS says, "Rerouting."
[laughter]
"There's a baboon trail a hundred yards behind
you and take a left." And we're also an all-weather
crew. A lot of our work, it's not rain-dependent.
And so, and you'll see in the sequence, actually
we got some really, really amazing rain dances
and rain displays as they were, as one community
was being aggressive towards another.
And so, it actually turned out to be really,
really important stuff to be able to shoot
in this kind of rain. And also, watch where
you step. If you can't--. There are days that
you can't find chimps. And you just walk and
walk and search and search, but those days
aren't boring 'cause you've run into people
like this.
This was about a seven-inch tall praying mantis
and rather than scurrying away scared this
thing--. I jumped out of my skin, I tell you,
because I'm always aware of snakes, whatever
might be on the ground. And this thing jumped
up like this--
[laughter]
and I jumped over there. Then, I walked towards
it to take a picture and the thing came towards
me like this.
[laughter]
It's like, "No way." So, I don't know. It's
like everything in that forest is fascinating.
[laughter]
Even the snakes are fascinating. This is a
rhinoceros viper. You can see the little,
I think those must be like nose smell sensors
that it's got. So, it has incredibly good
sense of smell and feel. And it was hiding
in the vegetation.
And the chimps streamed right past it. You
think the chimps are gonna be tuned in to
all the dangers around them. Well, there was
an estrous female there at the time. There's
a very popular female. They didn't even see
the snake at all. And they walked right past
it. I saw it kind of move, so I got a few
shots of it.
And so, I told everybody there was a snake
right there. Be really careful of that spot.
And you could hardly see it. And then, the
chimps started to compete over this female.
And so what did I do? I pick up my camera
and run right over here and start filming.
[laughter]
And it's only after the thing calmed down,
all this aggression calmed down, that I realized
I was standing right next to the snake, who
just took pity on my stupidity and allowed
me to live another day. Now, this guy came
right into camp. I thought it was a lobster,
but--.
[laughter]
It's a scorpion. Again, about six, seven inches
long, extraordinary and actually probably
less poisonous than the little tiny ones that
crawl into your clothes. Kristin did get stung
by one on the hand just going through paperwork.
And it put her out for about three days. She
hardly moved. Just moving her arm was agony
for three days. It was just awful. But not
everything in the forest is awful. I had to
throw this in for the Disney talk just because
of the Bambi effect of this little guy. We
were listening for chimps one day and this
little person came out of the forest and just
looking around, looked a little bit lost,
couldn't find mom and it's just adorable.
So, a lot of the wildlife, the birds and the
other wildlife, just fascinating as well.
So, what do I carry on my commute? People
ask me this all the time. And so, I decided
to just spread invisible Bill out on a table.
And so, I wear these big rubber boots to get
through those swamps. Ankle braces on both
sides.
Knee braces on both sides. I've been doing
this for 20 years. So, my joints are getting
a little bit stiff. Usually wear shorts. And
I take a little hand-held radio, so I can
talk in Swahili to the field assistance there.
Swiss Army knife, a pair of binoculars, GPS,
compass. The GPS is amazing because I can
figure out fig trees that are fruiting.
And then, if the chimps are hitting even remotely
there, then the next day I can swing and get
around them, be at the fig tree before the
chimps get there, being able to predict their
behavior. So, that's another way technology
really helps out. And I threw a slide in here
about that later on and then, my camera.
You can see the camera was about this big.
So, just to put that to scale. And there's
a rain cape underneath all that. There's plastic
bags to keep everything dry, a headlamp because
we leave at dark and often come back at dark,
extra batteries. A little bit of food. And
just some basic medical stuff and lots of
blister stuff. Go ahead.
>>Male #2: So, they just released a whole
series of 4K cameras the size of SLR's. Don't
you wish you shot this later?
>>Bill Wallauer: You know, there's never a
good time. That's a great question. And yes.
And we did utilize some of the DSLRs for a
lot of the scenic stuff. But in 2008, the
Panasonic 3700 was the cream of the crop.
I got the first one out in production in Europe.
I used the--. The drawback on some of these
cameras, like the Canon HJ series. So, I'm
carrying around equipment that's worth more
than my house--
[laughter]
through the jungles of Africa day after day.
So, it's kind of funny, but those are those
lenses that are just absolutely to die for.
And I don't even know if those smaller cameras
can utilize those longer lenses because with
the doubler, with the HJ 18, I think I can
shoot at the equivalent of around 12 to 15
hundred millimeter, which--.
We follow no closer than 20 feet just so we
don't interfere with anything the chimps might
be doing. So, we can't go in and get close.
We have to bring the chimps to us with our
long lenses. And that allowed us to get tight
shots that we've just never been allowed to
get before. But thanks for asking.
And if somebody else has a question while
I'm moving through this, shoot. Yeah. Go ahead.
>>Male #3: So, Google, I've seen on Cliff
bars and Cliffbuilders, things like that.
>>Bill Wallauer: Why don't they just sponsor
all of my work? That's what I wanna know.
[laughter]
>>Male #3: Do you get any of the bars, too,
or are you foraging?
>>Bill Wallauer: I am a foraging machine,
yeah.
[laughter]
And it's really interesting 'cause I've lived
in Gombe for all those years. And there's
some season that the food's not very nice.
And it's interesting. The chimps don't get
that excited about it. When they get really
excited it's over something super sweet. So,
there's that, there's a real connection between
us liking sweet and salty foods as well.
They're pretty rare. And those are the ones
in the forest I obviously like. It's the ones
they like as well. Also, if you're high-ranking,
you get the top of the tree because that's
where, if you think about this, in your own
backyard, if you have an apple tree, the juiciest,
ripest fruit is gonna be the highest stuff
in the tree because it's getting all the sunlight.
So, it's ripening better. And so, if you're
low-ranking, you're going to the lower parts
of the tree eating the lower fruit. If you're
high-ranking, you can be right in the top.
But yeah, Ilove chimp food. It's funny that
in certain times of year, I start craving.
I think there's a real connection between
what we used to eat just for nutrition and
also for like, for medicine.
There's a real correlation between that, because
I really crave some of this food that I no
longer get. There's something in arugula that's
really similar to what Jane called "chimp
spinach" all these years ago that I eat at
the end of the day that chimps just stuff
this stuff down at the end of the day. There's
some chemical in it that when arugula start
getting popular, it's like, "Oh, yeah. I feel
like I'm at home now."
[laughter]
>>Male #4: What percentage of the overlap
is it between what the chimps eat versus what
you'll eat? I mean, is there certain things
that they'll really go for that you don't?
>>Bill Wallauer: There are. Their sense of
bitter and sour, their ability to tolerate
that, is off the scale. But if I went with
you, mine would be off the scale compared
to most people 'cause my wife--.
>>Male #4: You could cook it and that cuts
it though.
>>Bill Wallauer: You could cook it. You could
cook it, like some of the fruit. But I mean,
some of it is to die for, like the wild plums
there or, the woodland fruits. They are, I
mean, better than anything we have here--really
just amazing.
And I would say that's probably less than
5%of the chimp food. And a lot of it is just
like they're just eating because that's the
only thing around. Go ahead. Great shirt,
by the way. What's that?
>>Male #5: Why are monkeys known to eat bananas?
[laughter]
>>Bill Wallauer: It's because people feed
them bananas.
[laughter]
It's not a natural food for them. And so,
I actually, it's sometimes to me, when I see
chimps in captivity, when I see chimps dressed
up, it's just heartbreaking to me because
it's not where in my heart I know chimps belong.
And so, that's why get that image because
have shown them eating bananas on television
and in pictures. But it's a not natural food
for them. Good question, though, and I love
your guy's shirts. You wanna stand up and
show everybody your shirts?
[laughter]
Yeah. This is what we want.
[clapping]
And also, there is nothing like being side-by-side
for all these years with the person I love,
being able to film chimps in the wild. I mean,
it's just absolutely the best job in the world.
In answer to your question about the tight
stuff that we can get.
These are just screen grabs, so from my HD
screen that--. You all know what a screen
grab is, right? Like, you just--. Well, at
your desk somebody didn't know what a screen
grab was. I said, "I need to go on Google
Earth and get a screen grab." And they said,
"What's a screen grab?" So anyway a screen
grab is like an image of the image you see
on your screen.
And as we were editing, I just threw some
of these up. And I mean, that is detailed,
is just extraordinary. That's over 20 feet
away. In the bottom right, that face, half
a chimp's face at 20 feet away. You'll see
in the film these lovely, the hands moving
through the hair as one male will groom another.
It just gave me an opportunity I'd never had
before with my little Sony camcorder, HD cameras.
So then, we get into the characters. When
you go and see the film, you'll meet this
guy. And why is a chimp, if you look at this
picture, look at that eye versus this one,
why would I key, as a cinematographer, on
this chimp?
Any ideas? Check his eyes out. Look at the
power of this shot when you can actually see
exactly where he's looking. Isn't that cool?
[laughter]
So, he's one of our bad guys. We built this
guy up as one of our enemies. And so,--
[laughter]
as the chimps were moving through the forest
and bearing down on Oscar and his family,
poor Pincer gets cast as the villain. And
it's simply because of his eyes, not because
he's a mean guy.
[laughter]
And yeah, here's another one, Lofty on the
right there. You'll see him in the film. He
is such a stud. A big, prime example of a
adult male chimp. And these guys are about
five times our strength. And so, they're just
extraordinary physical machines. Go ahead.
>>Female #1: How do you keep track of who's
who?
>>Bill Wallauer: The same way you all keep
track of who's who here. And it's really strange.
The first time you get there, you think, "How
can anybody tell all these chimps apart?"
And now, I can hear their call from a half
a mile away and I say, "That's Freud. That's
Frodo. That's Apollo. That's Atlas." It's
just like we do in our own culture, but it's
interesting.
I grew up in really rural Oregon and so, I
hadn't had a lot of cultural diversity, not
in the school that I went to. And so, when
I first went to Africa, there was, I didn't
have with African American faces, I didn't
have, or African faces, I didn't have that
ability to differentiate different traits.
And this is true right across the board that
we get used, in our own culture, the differentiating
traits that are familiar to us.
And I had to learn that about chimps as well,
that though they all look the same, I need
to use different cues that I'm used to using
to recognize people. And you do see that Lofty
has a dark beard there. But they both have
black faces. So, in poor light conditions,
you might get these two mixed up. But he has
a little bit of a tattered ear.
So, over time, you get more and more accustomed
to figuring out who they are. And then after,
like with this community, after being in Gombe
for 15 years and then following these guys,
I guess within 2½ weeks, I had 35 of the
chimps down, committed to memory. So, and
I'm not really very good with faces, human
faces.
[laughter]
And I just threw this in just to shout out
for my wife. My job is hard as a cinematographer,
but I can always dial in some game and the
chimps are moving. For her, to get chimps
to stop at that slow shutter speed, if any
of you are photographers or technicians, every
once in a while all the elements come together.
This beam of light came down onto Burg here.
And she can get these wonderful shots of his
beautiful amber eyes. But it's so hard. Her
job is much harder than mine even. And then,
here's our ultimate villain.
[laughter]
And you'll meet Scar in the movie. And this
is Scar. He's a grumpy old man, who is the
leader of the villains.
[laughter]
And so, my job, a big part of my job was to
record this territorial behavior. So, we have
Oscar and his group in the film. And then,
we have Hair and the villains, who'd come
in and that's very true about the nature of
chimp society. Each community has a home range,
which overlaps with three or four other home
ranges.
And they compete for no man's land, or no
chimp's land, the overlapping territory. And
if a strong community can, they will completely
take over another community. So, in this case,
these guys--. And they're no better conservationists
than we've exhibited in the last 15, 20 years.
These guys wiped out all of the colobus monkeys
in the home range.
They hunted them down and ate all of them.
And so, they started going farther and farther
out to patrol and search for monkeys, which
means they move farther and farther into the
neighboring communities' range but also after
fruit and nut trees as well. The biggest challenge
for me, though, was to actually get around
them.
So, they're moving in these beautiful long
patrol-like lines. They stop calling. They
stop exhibiting other behavior. It's very
much like a military patrol. It's just extraordinary.
And so, my job is to get them, and you'll
see in the film, these shots as they're coming
towards you.
But that means I have to be traveling in faster-than-chimp
speed, which at times seems like it's faster
than light 'cause they move so quickly. But
I did manage to get enough for this film to
make a really powerful story. And another
thing I--. Oh, go ahead. Do you have a question?
>>Male #5: Would you say you had a story you
create in the movie?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah.
>>Male #5: Or is this what you actually experienced
out there? Would you say they end up playing
each other's characters?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yes.
>>Male #5: Is not really there?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah.
>>Male #5: And a lot of times, Disney is criticized
for doing the good versus bad, herbivores
versus carnivores.
>>Bill Wallauer: Absolutely. And I had to,
as primarily a researcher and research videographer,
I go to these conferences, the International
Primate Behavioral Conferences. And so, I
have a status as a behaviorist as much as
I do as a filmmaker. And so, I have to make
sure my films are true to science.
And of course, when you're shooting a film,
it isn't chronological. It doesn't happen
just in the way. There's always going to be
some license, but the line we can't cross
is the line of changing chimp behavior. And
of course, producers, who don't understand
chimp behavior, are constantly saying, "Can
we say this? Can we say that? Can we say it
this way?"
"No. No and no." So, I choose my battles.
And if it's one over maybe a subtle vocalization,
I might not fight that one as hard as I would
as if they were like, completely changing
chimp behavior. But when they built these
villains up as villains, of course, in their
own community they're not villains. They're
the same guys that you'll see in Oscar's community,
Freddie and the bunch.
But to the neighboring community, they're
very much. And those will be the guys that
you see. Those are the chimps who you are
going to be scared of as a neighboring community
member. And so, it is telling that story of
the way these overlapping communities defend
and protect their territory and actually extend
their own territory into another's.
And as far as character base, we did take
a little bit of licenses as far as Pincer
is not the toughest chimp in the world. But
does that matter as much as the demonstrating
the behavior well? And that's more important
to me. But it's a really good question. It's
one we should rethink over and over. And I
appreciate questions like that.
So, how far should I push those bounds before
we can say, "That's something I'm not proud
of anymore." And I've actually taken my name
off films in the credits because I came to
such a split with the production team that
I could no longer be proud and want my name
on that production.
>>Male #6: So--.
>>Bill Wallauer: Yes.
>>Male #6: How much of the narrative did Disney
comes to and say, "This is the narrative.
Can you go film it?" Where they said, "We
wanna film chimpanzees. You film stuff and
we'll figure out the narrative."
>>Bill Wallauer: Luckily, we had our working
team was the same people who do the "Planet
Earth," "Blue Planet," "Life of Mammals" team.
So, it wasn't a Disney-based idea. It was
the three of us sitting down and figuring
out, take chimpanzee behavior. What of chimpanzee
behavior do we want to run?
And put a script and time-line together, leaving
room for things that might change. And sequences
like this; the hunting sequence was something
we could have never scripted. And guess what.
After years of planning and putting this all
together, within about a year, we had thrown
two or three of the original scripts away
just because of things that happened on the
ground.
And for me, it's just--. I'm just a documentarian.
I'm gonna follow the strongest story that
is going on. And so, the chimps really are
the ones who tell the best story. And it's
up to me to be able to follow and document
that story. So, even though we did have an
idea of what we wanted to do, in the end,
at the end of the three years, we had a stronger
story than anything we'd come up with. But
thanks. That's a great question. Go ahead.
>>Male #7: So, when I wanna shoot animals
with dark fur and shadow detail and so on,
it's very hard.
>>Bill Wallauer: It is very hard, isn't it?
>>Male #7: So, are the days that are like
this just working and you can't shoot dark
or like, Disney films only stop?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah. And for a Disney film
like this, every shot has to be a postcard
if you can imagine. That was my mantra. So,
there were days that I would get nothing that
made the film. So, I mean, you could follow
for--. 'Cause I think we'd do six days off
or, yeah, sx days off and one day on. That's
a pretty good schedule.
[laughter]
No, it's six days off and then one day on.
You know what I'm saying.
[laughter]
So, in that six days of working, we would
get, some days, almost nothing usable for
the film. And it would simply be because of
the light, because of something going on.
And at the end of the third day, and you're
thinking, "I just wanna go back home. It looks
like it's gonna rain."
You hang on for another two hours and then
you'd get a sequence like this that just makes
the film. And this was the African killer
bees on Oscar. He just dug into this nest.
And--
[laughter]
I mean, it was scary, but this was within
like, three or four days of wrapping the whole
film and that's what I loved about chimp behavior.
You never know what's gonna happen next. And
so, you can just keep following and following.
And yeah, I mean, if you're not as enthralled
with your subject as I am, you do sometimes
wanna just say, "This isn't worth the time
I'm investing." 'Cause it is a huge--. I was
shooting at something like 150-to-1 ratio,
meaning for every minute that might make the
film, probably even more, there's an hour
and a half, yeah.
Two and a half hours of footage sitting somewhere
that's never gonna be seen. And that's the
stuff that I did shoot. And so, imagine the
ratio of time is just sub-fractional. Absolutely.
And we just had to wait for the best light
and wait for the best situations. Go ahead.
>>Male #8: What was the most dangerous moment
that you felt?
>>Bill Wallauer: The most dangerous moment?
>>Male #8: Yeah, with the chimps.
>>Bill Wallauer: The most dangerous moment
for me was the day that we got back to camp
and it was the day that I'd run a whole herd
of buffalo over my wife.
[laughter]
So, that was dangerous for me when I got back
to camp. It's much more dangerous for her
when she was in the field. But that was the
scariest moment that I'm saying. We'd gone
around this bend. Kristin was coming along
behind us. And I was saying "this is where
we are" and I was giving her some geographic
marker of where we were.
And right then, I heard this thundering to
my left. And it was a herd of buffalo running
from me. They'd winded me. And they ran straight
in Kristin's direction. And they ran through
a valley and could just come up the other
side and run right into them. Luckily, they
took the valley for cover. But they were really
scared.
She and James were really scared and they
ran as fast as they could to get away. And
I'm sure there's a few times that I don't
even know about, like times that I stepped
over a snake and didn't know. But that's probably
the most dangerous stuff. And you pick up
malaria a few times. What's that?
>>Male #8: You never feel dangerous with the
chimpanzee?
>>Bill Wallauer: Never with chimps, never
ever. They've been followed by the researchers
for decades. And they're used to having people
around. And even in the heart of those battles,
I never feel like they're gonna do something
to me. It's very humbling, though, when you
see that kind of power that they'll just grab
a branch and break a tree in two.
It's just extraordinary. So, it's really humbling
in that respect. And they have canines, extraordinary
canines. They could do me in in seconds if
they wanted to. And so, after 20 years, you
feel like you have, hopefully, a certain report.
Go ahead.
>>Male #9: Did they ever acknowledge you?
>>Bill Wallauer: They don't. I mean, my job
is to be a fly on the wall both as a researcher
and as a filmmaker. My best day is when no
chimp even looks up at me when I'm filming.
And you'll see as you're watching the film
that there's very little eye contact between
the chimp and the camera.
They're very seldom looking at us. They're
just doing their thing. So, this is the African
killer bee sequence. So, the bees are buzzing
around everywhere. And these guys are digging
into this nest. It's just amazing.
[laughter]
Look at that honey. It's just amazing. But
if that was me, I would probably survive about
30 seconds. That would just do a human in.
But they are going to town. And then there's
the fig-eating sequence that I went for two
weeks. I stood in a three by three platform
in the top of the next tree over from our
big Mama Macuso fig tree. And just to get
a different angle of the chimps. And so, this
is that day's commute. This is my elevator.
[laughter]
And so, I took some self-portraits of myself
as I'm going up. But look at the ropes going
down into the abyss. [laughs]
[pause]
And so, I spent a couple weeks doing this.
And this was my little, that was my place
in the forest for about two weeks. But there
is on the way down--. Oh, it's not supposed
to, oh, yeah, I guess it is. Just to have
that kind of angle and be able to shoot down
and across as the chimps are in this frame
was a really extraordinary experience. And
one the way down, the first steps is a real
doozy.
[laughter]
To be hanging like you're 120 feet up above
the canopy is it's funny. You're tied in,
but there's a real freedom to that, that you
see the forest and hear sounds and experience
smells that you're just not accustomed to
down in the forest floor. So, it was a real
treat to get to do this. And during this sequence,
this guy actually made the film. And he so
reminded us of that squirrel from "Ice Age"
with his bug eyes.
[laughter]
And so, even if we didn't have chimps there,
we had all kinds of other species at this
fig tree to keep us company. That's a red-tailed
monkey on the left and a grey-cheeked mangabey
in the upper right. And you can get shots
like this.
[pause]
And I was saying what I do on my GPS. Well,
these are my way points. And it actually does
make me a better filmmaker. I just grab this
off Google Earth's site. You'll see areas
like the elephant wallow up there. I'd always
want to get there first before the chimps
did so I can have them coming into this area.
There were hunts right around in there, so
if I know that they're heading towards area
there are hunts, I'll go out in front, try
to figure out where the colobus monkeys are
so I can get a jump on the hunt. And so, as
a tool, it's so much fun for me to come home
and relive. I have a date on all of these
way points.
Relive on Google Earth all of my experiences
out in the forest. I filled my entire GPS
with way points [laughs] during the filming
of "Chimpanzee."
>>Male #10: You need to [inaudible] Street
View trailer.
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah, I do. [laughs]
And so, getting one of the luxuries of getting
to shoot for Disney Nature is we had a huge
budget and three years to do this film. So,
really time was very, very much on my side
for the making of this film. And sadly, as
a juxtaposition, I can't say the same for
chimps. Time is definitely not on their side.
This is about what their range was, even within
the last hundred or so years, this whole equatorial
forest belt, incredibly wide, right across
Africa. And just in 80 years of technology,
chainsaws, demand for African hardwoods, these
areas have been very, very much fragmented.
That whole central area completely gone, fragments
in the far West of Africa. And that's what
we're all about now is doing everything we
can do to preserve chimps and chimp habitat.
During the 90s, I shot this video of Jane.
And this was when she was realizing, and it's
the history of her realizing that she's gotten
so much from the chimps and it was time for
her to do something for them. So, I'm gonna
play this video. Again, I shot this, I guess
around 1999, but it's still very relevant.
[plays video]
>>Jane Goodall: About seven years ago, I--.
>>Bill Wallauer: That's just outside of Gombe
National Park.
>>Jane Goodall: And I was absolutely horrified
at what I saw. So quickly it seemed the environment
outside the National Park had been utterly
destroyed. The trees had gone. When I came
in 1960, you could go in a boat and go right
up to Bolivia.
It was chimp habitat. You could climb up the
hills of [ ] and look eastward--chimp habitat
as far as you could see. And that's gone.
It's only within the 30 square mile path that
the original forest remains. The question
then was, when people are struggling to survive,
how is it possible to protect the precious
oasis of the Gombe forest with its very famous
chimpanzees?
And that's how TACARE came into being--a program
to try and improve the lives of the local
people and the villages surrounding the path
and up and down the lake shore.
[end video]
>>Bill Wallauer: And so, that's our great
work is when you're working with people who
are absolutely destitute in a country that's
arguably nine thousand miles away from the
wealthiest country in the world, that is a
real challenge.
You're seeing the forest on the outside of
the park disappear. You saw some of those
shots. That was chimp habitat when Jane arrived
in 1960. And so, our huge challenge now is
to slow down that tide and actually turn it
at some point. And Jane's visionary work not
only was research in 1960, but realizing that
absolutely you have to work with and have
people benefit from conservation work.
And that's her other great pioneering work.
And so, we're not just a chimp conservation
organization. We're very, very much both humanitarian
and many, many, many programs that I very
much encourage you to check our website out
and look at Jane's vision. Read some of her
books. But what are the threats to chimps?
Certainly the global demand for African hardwoods
and the lumber that comes out of these forests,
unsustainable agriculture, slash and burn
agriculture. The bush meat trade is also very,
very devastating, has a very devastating impact
on chimps. And the illegal animal trade as
well has a huge impact on chimpanzee populations.
And so, with this demand, these are local
people are just struggling to make a living
cutting down more forest, creating--. This
is just outside of chimp habitat. Trying to
farm in these areas. And then resulting in
the soil washing down from the slopes and
that all goes away. So, they start the whole
process over again, time and time again.
So, this TACARE program that we've started
around Gombe, we're trying to emulate in sites
right across Africa now. So, in Tanzania,
we have Tanzanian nurses going out, do interfacing
with local people. We'll go to a village and
find out "What are your biggest needs?" "Well,
we don't have a dispensary here." And so,
we'll raise funds.
We'll work with local people. We'll start
a dispensary. And we have staff who are absolute
experts in the field. We have a wonderful
savings and credit scheme, so that we train
women up who actually invest in their own
scheme. A group of women will come and invest
in their own scheme. We have a matching fund
for that.
And that very much empowers women to be gainfully
employed using their own resources and their
own businesses. In this case, this woman,
fabulous woman, had started a grain grinding
system in her own little village. And now,
people are bringing grain to her and she's
exporting that and she's making a lot of money
where she wouldn't have had this opportunity
before.
Also, inexpensive ways to solve problems.
Our team developed the Vetiveria grass, which
is a bunch grass, which creates, when planted
across these slopes like this, creates terrace
agriculture, which, terrace agriculture, there's
a real science, very difficult to do. This
system is incredibly cheap, incredibly effective,
and this field will now be used for decades
rather than for two years.
And also, once we start protecting the forests
and start doing forest management, cash crop
such as honey come into play in the villages.
And so, we have this honey distribution system
and honey bee program, which helps local villages
to actually make money by having forest maintained
and healthy.
And also, I don’t know if you've heard about
Jane's Roots and Shoots program, but this
is an amazing program. It's now in 130 countries
around the world. I encourage you to definitely
look more into this. It's all about empowering
kids to make the world a better place for
people, animals, and the environment.
And what better message in this day and age
can you give kids? And it's got this global
feel about it as well. So, kids in Tanzania,
they could be chatting with kids in China.
They can be chatting with kids in the US,
all working towards those three main goals,
which is just fabulous. And this story has
a very local feel.
A very good friend of mine, Deborah Simons,
is a San Franciscan. And actually, she lives
right around here. And she is a manager of
the Wanda Bobowski Fund, which is a scholarship
for young girls. And she came and visited
Gombe years ago, fell in love with the place,
saw that especially young women had a very
rough time in the world there.
And so now, over 200 young women have been
issued these scholarship. And Yaku Pica here,
the young woman on the left, was an orphaned
destitute, had absolutely zero future and
her headmaster identified her as a great student.
She applied for the fund. She got a scholarship.
She worked up through college.
She got a position at a local elementary school.
I was there. I filmed her teaching science
to her kids and she was talking about the
qualities of the magnet to these, I guess
they would be about third grade kids. Just
so much fun. So enthusiastic. When you think
about, "Well, what impact could this possibly
have?"
Well, Yaku Pica's kids could grow up to be
the next leaders of the generation. She could
grow up to be a government leader. She could
be the first woman president in Tanzania.
You get a generation of kids thinking differently
about the world, finding hope in the world,
and you're really gonna have a major influence
on the next generation's philosophical ideals
and so forth.
And it's so important in this day and age.
And so, this is Yaku Pica's challenge. This
is her classroom on the right. Its 70 kids
who she teaches. So, it is an extraordinary
challenge, but she's done a wonderful job.
Some of you in Google Earth know Lillian Pintea,
who's our IT guy and our GIS guy. And so,
just for him, I threw a few slides in for
his benefit as well.
We work a lot with Google Earth. We have this
new Open Data Kit program. So, we have forest
monitors who take--. And you're involved with
I don't know if anybody in this room is involved
in this program, but Android phones, which
can be through the Open Data Kit program.
They turned into these incredible, incredibly
powerful data collecting machines.
And so, we have a whole bunch of forest monitors
and patrollers who are traveling through the
forest and through the areas of West Africa
or of Western Tanzania. Oh, we have to wrap
up pretty quick. Oh. Getting on this. What's
the time?
>>Female #2: It's two o'clock.
>>Bill Wallauer: It's two o'clock now? Oh,
gosh. 'Cause we have some Q and A, don't we?
[laughter]
So, anyway, we are doing some awesome work
with Google and Lillian's going to shoot me
because I didn't talk enough about this.
[laughter]
But anyway, these are our guys in the field
doing awesome stuff with Google. Yeah, look
some of that stuff up as well. But I would
love to answer some questions. I'm sorry I've
gone on too long, but should we go straight
to some questions? Yeah? Anybody have any
questions? Not so much. [laughs] Oh, go ahead.
>>Male #11: So, would you say that it's groups
of chimpanzees that will battle each other?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yes.
>>Male #11: For their territory?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah.
>>Male #11: You said they beat each other?
>>Bill Wallauer: Really, they will kill one
another. Yeah, the adults will kill one another
for sure. Absolutely.
>>Male #11: Anyway, do the tribes merge or
groups merge?
>>Bill Wallauer: The only genetic, as far
as spreading genetics from one community to
another, the females do that. So, at about
age 12 or 13, when the females become reproductively
active, they're likely to transfer from one
community to another. So, they are the only
accepted ones. If a male gets caught on that
border trying, on that no chimp's land, he's
definitely gonna get attacked.
So, that's how genetic diversity is maintained
is through the female transfer from one community
to another.
>>Male #12: If one group takes over another
group's area, will they just wipe out the
whole--?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah. They will either be
shifted to a much smaller area or they could
be completely eliminated over time. And you
might incorporate the females from that community
into your group. Yeah. Yes, go ahead.
>>Male #13: So, this may be more for your
wife then, than you. But what percentage of
the sound in a film like this is fully, or
from other periods rather than actually being
live sound?
>>Bill Wallauer: As far as sync sound versus
wild track or--? Yeah. I mean, we could do
sync sound some of the time, but because I'm
a noisy cameraman, she would have to go off
with a different--.
Within the community, there could be four
or five or six different subgroups. And so,
she would hang out with other chimps. And
then, we'd sync sound up later. So, it's not,
the sounds that you hear are often not true
to the voice of the individual you're seeing.
[laughs] But I think most people won't notice
that, but there are some.
[laughter]
There are some sync sound shots, like the
drumming display that you'll see Scar do,
that was sync sound. But that was your question
as far as the sync sound stuff? Yeah. Go ahead.
>>Male #14: [inaudible] following bonobos.
[inaudible] their behavior [inaudible] see
one of them [inaudible]?
>>Bill Wallauer: Bonobos live in such unstable
parts of the world. And I've been a chimp
person for so long, I don't even get to many
of the other chimp sites. And so, I've never
been south of the Congo in the Congo Basin
to see bonobos.
For those of you who don't know, bonobos are
another one of our closest living relatives.
They're very chimp-like, but they're not chimps.
But they have their own different cultural
repertoire and behavioral repertoire. They're
very similar looking to chimps, but they are
very different in behavior. And no, I haven't
spent any time with them. I would love to.
Absolutely love to. Any other questions? Go
ahead.
>>Male #15: Do you focus on a particular tribe
or do you familiar with all of them?
>>Bill Wallauer: There are about 12 study
sites across Africa. I've spent quite a bit
of time in three of those sites, but the vast
majority of my work has been in Jane's Gombe
National Park in Tanzania and so, yeah. Most
of my work has been there, but for the film,
just one or two sites for the film. Yep. Go
ahead.
>>Male #16: You talked about some of the things
that you've doing with Google that are really
great , particularly apps and some things
that nobody's thought of?
>>Bill Wallauer: That maybe none of you have
thought of? Well, it would be fun to sit down
and have a creative meeting. We were talking
with Winnie before during lunch today. And
you can imagine from a filmmaker's point of
view, how much fun it would be to do live
feeds.
Like, you could get on Google Earth, double-click
and it's Bill, right now, real time, following
Gremlin and the twins. I mean, that would
be unbelievable. And I was also brainstorming
there. I mean to have a fig tree, like the
one I showed you here, that has a 24/7 live
feed to see who comes into that tree over
the course of a day.
We could also do really nice conservation
work with it, too. So, I mean, I think there's
some really interesting applications. It would
be great to sit down with some Google minds
and have some brainstorming sessions about
how we could actually--. And that's my whole
work is capturing people with chimps and chimp's
behavior, but then going to the next level
and saying, "Yeah. Chimps are seriously endangered.
Let's see what we can do to get more and more
people interested and engaged and involved."
And that would be a wonderful goal if you
wanna talk to me afterward. [laughs] Anything
else? Anybody else? Yeah. Go ahead.
>>Female #3: Are there estimates as to how
many chimps are left in the world right now?
>>Bill Wallauer: Yeah. That slide I showed.
Around 1900, there were one to two million.
Now, there are fewer than 300 thousand. So,
we probably lost 60% of them in my lifetime.
They could be completely gone. I always have
this slide in here. Again, preaching to the
choir, I'm sure you all are aware of this.
Just be very, very sure of where your dollars
are going. Check out our institute. Support
the Jane Goodall Institute. It's very difficult
to do conservation work nine thousand miles
away from where people will ever have contact,
the species you're trying to conserve.
So, we have some really, really big challenges,
but it's with people's support like yours
that we will make it so the next generation
so, these kids can maybe someday go to Africa
with their kids and see chimps. And that's
my goal, seven generations away. So anyway,
thank you so much for your time and your interest.
And thank you so much.
[applause]